can you explain what
dark matter is great question so
i can answer that in by saying yes i'll
answer that and then i can say also i
have no idea
and scientists don't have any idea so
let me explain
so our universe is made up of matter and
we know that already and we
understand how matter works because in
essence
it it it has gravity it there is a
gravitational field so the fact that you
and i
are sitting on the earth is the fact
that we have mass and
we're you know we behave you know you
jump off a two-story building
you will experience gravity and it's not
going to come out good
and so if we study how objects behave in
our universe
and we can see how they move then we
understand
something about the mass of that
particle right or the mass of the object
because
of the way that gravity works but in the
late 1990s
and and subsequently um there are a
series of experiments
a cosmological experience astronomical
experiments were studying galaxies
that discussed that looked at how they
actually rotated how they moved
in a circle and they discovered that if
they measured all the mass
in that galaxy um
it did not and therefore work out how
much matter there was
from by measuring how fast it spun
remember based on gravity
they had a problem because if they
measured the mass by counting the number
of stars and all the gases in there that
they can read off
and then measure the mass about how it
behaves under gravity
the mass that it had was far far higher
than what they measured in other words
the
galaxy and other galaxies as well not
just one galaxy but other galaxies and
how they work
work had far more mass
than what we measured so in other words
there's some matter there
some stuff that has mass but we can't
measure it
directly but it is there
so we have no idea what it is
dark matter so so as a result
you know we discover that there's a
significant portion of our universe that
has
gives it far more mass but we can't
measure it directly whenever we try to
compare it
to our direct measurements of matter by
measuring
the stars or measuring you know and it
can be can be done
quite with quite great precision and how
much you know about the gas that's there
they always come up less and then
there's a second problem
the other aspect is that the universe we
know
is expanding but because the universe
has mass overall
the initial view is that well hopefully
what that does is that the gravity
because of the expansion is due to the
big bang
and hopefully will happen is that mass
will cause gravity cause it to come back
in again
and now and so you know if if you read
the textbooks of the
uh 70s and 80s they said well what's the
universe going to be ending like well
maybe we'll have what we call the big
big crunch the universe will expand
and then collapse in of itself and then
repeat the process
or maybe it's going to be static so it's
going to be just the point where it just
grows and eventually the expansion is
about equal to the gravity and it'll
just
sit there like that what they discovered
and uh which uh by the uh scientists by
the name of brian
schmidt got a nobel prize he and his
team four
in 2011 is that the universe is not just
moving out it's speeding up it's going
faster and faster out
and so they came the idea is that well
this
this other energy that is actually
driving the universe
outwards that goes against gravity
or negative energy if you want to say it
that way and that came the term
dark energy so whenever you talk to
scientists astronomers about dark matter
inevitably they will also raise the idea
of dark energy
that there is the universe but if we
measure the universe that only five
percent of our total universe is
ordinary matter
everything else is dark matter and dark
energy
and so you know the question then
is well what is that matter right and
this is the question you really ask what
is dark matter it's the matter out there
that we can't measure
but clearly it's having its influence on
our universe
but we don't know what it is so um
there are weird types of names that
scientists
give to the possible reasons
for what this dark matter is terms
such as cue balls which is a weird name
wimps which basically means for weak
interacting
massive particles but they don't know
what it is
right it's just a name and one of cern's
desires in their experiments is that if
they smash the particles
protons hadrons or whatever and other
the other particle accelerators that
occur there
is maybe they can find some evidence
for particles that could explain
that missing matter but like i said the
big
problem with dark matter is it's it
it we can't detect it and the way that
we detect it
is either it has an electrical charge so
we can bend it in
electric fields and magnetic fields or
it gives off radiation
um and but it doesn't none of that
and so you know you can fire stuff at it
you know if you wanted to do it that way
but if it doesn't interact with it
then you'll never know you'll never know
that it exists there you know the fact
that you are staring at my screen
and seeing me is because light's hitting
me and
bouncing off and hitting the camera and
it's interacting with me
right and you therefore know i'm sitting
there and i know you're sitting there
but if the light passes straight through
me
then you'd never know i was there right
so
the fact is that light or particles has
to somehow interact with me
and cause me to do something to that in
order to measure it
and that's the problem with dark matter
we look for all the ways of trying to
do something hit it with something or in
the case of particle excited excitators
try to discover particles that could
have the properties
that would explain why we don't see it
in our galaxies but it's there
it's there but we just don't no you know
we don't we can't directly measure it
and then that's dark matter
right it's dark because we don't know
what it is you know it's out of ours
out of our vision so to speak but it's
definitely showing
i